attention vous entrez dans un monde sans
mensonge
[Musique]
à
et voilà non ça sent bon alors comment
ça va ta visite pas terrible pas
terrible et quand tu m'appelles comme ça
ça me déprime et ben écoute avec a pas
de tirer sur le zig ou d'entretien
c'est vrai que c'est chiant de chantal
faut toujours que tu es humilier les
gens dès que tu peux c'est plus fort que
moi je peux pas m'empêcher autrement je
ne peux pas me rayer en société déjà
qu'en ce moment je suis pas au top parce
que ta copine tu as quitté ses les
parties pourra mettre beaucoup mieux de
toi parce que parce qu'il a fallu que tu
t'en ailles de l'appartement une main
devant une main derrière pas dans mon
chéri mettez un peu ch ou chattes non la
tête d'urgente and i les poches a shot
il est fragile moi même j'ai beaucoup
pleuré ya pas si longtemps que ça
bah oui la mort de tonton jacquot non
non mais quand cindy s'est fait éliminer
de la maison de mystère tous il va
passer mais ce point
voilà tu manges pas non non c'est
dégueulasse vous voulez dire ton père et
moi on est très déçu que tu travailles
dans la pub c'est pourquoi j'ai mis ma
vie
oui mais les voisins à leurs enfants
sont médecins aux pompiers ingénieurs et
nous qu'est ce qu'on dit dans les dîners
la plus pour les rillettes
oui c'est notre fils le déaut pour les
chiottes bah oui c'est lui aussi pas de
la merde quoi de la merde tu sais mon
chéri je pense que ta copine elle a eu
raison de te quitter je vais vous dire
un truc déjà je mange avec vous ce
métier alors franchement j'ai beaucoup
mieux à faire mais si juste veut avoir
un petit peu de compassion entre
l'entrée les serres vous cache pas que
ça m'arrange
voilà tu sais nous les femmes on aime
les hommes les vrais ceux qui n'hésitent
pas te mettre une petite fille c'est au
centre mais pourquoi tu ne choisis pas
pas nouveau c'était pas mon premier
choix
qu'est ce que c'est un bal des pompiers
qui dérape une cartouche neuf mois après
et la voilà
[Musique]